après des mois de confinement
les résidents du centre d'hébergement
champlain ont reçu de la belle visite
durant une vingtaine de minutes quatre
musiciens de l'om ont interprété des
airs populaires qui ont visiblement
réjoui les spectateurs chargé jusqu'au
j' ai dit du ciel sachez l'hygiène
depuis le début de la pandémie les
résidents et le personnel des ch et cd
ont été durement éprouvées le concert
d'aujourd'hui était une bulle de
réconfort très attendu ces gens là ont
vécu un confinement très très difficile
avec pas de visite
on a eu des employés qui ont été touchés
aussi par la maladie je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un cadeau on leur
fait c'est un moment de grâce que
l'orchestré symphonique de montréal
offre à nos résidents nous intervenons
pour moi c'était vraiment innovante en
pôles de pouvoir assister à ce concert
pour les musiciens de l'ouest m6 mini
concerts permettent d'exprimer leur
solidarité et de donner un sens à leur
métier et à leur passion nous au moins
on apporter un petit baume six minimes
mais on espère que ça va donner du
bonheur pour les livres continuent à
passer au travers de cette période
difficile et les résultats sont probants
il ya une dame qui venait me voir après
la présentation qui me dit vous savez
votre musique
on rapporte ramené de la motricité sur
certaines aux patients
l'orchestré pourrait offrir d'autres
concerts de ce type dans les ch et celle
des au cours de l'été parce que parfois
la musique est le meilleur antidote les
petits jeunes de piscine a dit alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal